[Music]
this morning in the dish a taste of the
middle east james beard award-winning
chef sammy tamimi grew up in east
jerusalem and went on to become corner
of london's famed ottolengi restaurant
group where tara wigley has worked for a
decade they've each co-authored
best-selling cookbooks now they've
collaborated on one of their own
phallisteen a celebration of tamimi's
palestinian homeland mt is taiyab went
to meet them and talk about the tastes
smells and history that have brought
them together
hello everyone if there's one place sami
tamimi truly feels at home
it's in the kitchen but the london-based
palestinian chef doesn't slave over a
hot stove as much as he once used to can
i eat that's because the deli he and his
israeli-born business partner yota
montelengi started nearly 20 years ago
has now grown into a major food empire
but it was when the jew were putting
together their 2012 bestseller jerusalem
that tamimi began his own journey home
to write the cookbook called palestine
the arabic word for palestine
it's also a love letter to you know the
place that i grew up in and my family
the country the food the people
tanimi was just 17 years old when he
left his family home in the old city of
east jerusalem to work at restaurants in
west jerusalem and tel aviv
it was an era of unpredictable violence
and when a job offer came to run a deli
in london
he took it
you moved to london in 1997 uh in the
backdrop of a lot of violence uh in
in israel and palestine what was it like
being so far from home with
so much violence going on at the same
time it was heartbreaking and you know
hearing i mean it's
really sad that so many people or
innocent people died for
no reason
and
but
i was busy cooking i was you know
celebrating the food and the cooking and
this kept me
in a way kind of
insane
the move and a new found friendship
would soon change to mimi's life
you come to london you're you're working
in great kitchens um and you happen to
meet a guy named yotam what was that
what happened there i guess we kind of
um connected because
we both
grew up in the same place jerusalem in
different parts of jerusalem we decided
to open otolengi and uh
it worked for us
it's worked pretty well
secret hermes
ice cold water tara wigley a veteran of
the now ottolengi group is the co-writer
of palestine that's right and help
tamimi choose the recipes that offer a
window into the lives of palestinians
who live and cook in often challenging
circumstances
i used to live in jerusalem i know that
so much can be politicized including
food and yet the book doesn't shy away
from that was that really important for
you to convey that in this cookbook
everything that you touch in this region
turns into politics and we don't want to
we didn't want to shy from it but we had
to be careful how to say things to
convey the situation back home
a reality that wigley says needed to be
shown
every single recipe and every single
word and every single story
was
was done really really thoughtfully and
with a really big sense of
responsibility tamimi and wigley
traveled from bethlehem to nazareth
haifa to nablus to gather the stories
and flavors of palestine the cookbook is
written with the home chef in mind
i started saying that with recipes like
hussein's easy eggs named after tamimi's
father made with zatar and green onion
and muhamra a hearty dip of blended
walnuts and peppers it tastes like
summer
look at the weather
[Laughter]
there's a real sort of fruitiness to it
it's the lemon and the pomegranate
molasses and there's also the sweetness
from the peppers
then there's the impossibly smooth
hummus one topped with seasoned beef
meatballs the other with fried eggplant
the eggplant really kind of absorbs the
flavor doesn't it
it's a real nice contrast
it's really good philistine is not only
a celebration of palestinian cooking
it also encourages readers to break
bread with others
the idea that all of it is meant to be
shared i think is really beautiful thing
yeah
it also tastes really good
delicious food and distinctly
palestinian flavors made from the heart
what does it mean to you to share it
with the world
makes me happy i'm inside i'm this big
mama that want to feed everyone
for cbs saturday morning infyas tayab
london
the big mama that wants to feed everyone
oh my god who's hungry i'm starving
i'm thirsty right i've gotta try the
hummus we have a toast after the show to
celebrate our new we gotta have us well
we gotta have drinks on a saturday and
homeless too we can have whatever you
want whatever you want don't worry